l'anniversaire le plus étoilé du moment
autour de paul bocuse pour fêter ses 81
ans les plus grands chefs venus du monde
entier ont participé à ce but fait
d'exception olivier terran virgilia
d'eau ils sont venus des quatre coins du
monde avec leur savoir faire et leur
passion ils sont venus pour
l'anniversaire de monsieur paul bocuse
une plis des toiles pour ses 80 bougies
qu'elle brille à la croix les meilleurs
chefs du mans le temps là où ça vous
aimez vous at il à faire
formidable dans les cuisines du louis 15
le 3 étoiles d'alain ducasse la brigade
est en ébullition donc beaucoup
d'émotion au congrès le grand personnage
se sent toujours chez lui dans une
cuisine
l' envie de composer intacte damrau mai
soit un pas en arrière
c'est la jeunesse éternelle en fait la
cuisine pour la famille c'est l'autre
chef incontournable de la cuisine
française alain ducasse qui a organisé
l'hommage à susciter un intérêt et je
pense que c'est bien pour paul nous
sommes encore là et pour longtemps
comme cadeau l'échelle du monde ont
organisé un petit buffet où la
gastronomie se conjugue avec les
continents du filet de rennes à la crème
brûlée au foie gras de yoshito du japon
anne sophie pic de paris même adria
feram du restaurant el bulli est venu à
monaco témoigner pour l'espagne c'est la
même chose pour mobiles pour la presse
incroyable aujourd'hui l'hommage
savoureux s'est complu dans la salle
empire de l'hôtel de paris pour un
hommage à l'image de la cuisine ou
savoir faire et faire savoir sont
désormais moléculaire mans liés